الان كما يبدو رشقات صاروخيه جديده
هذا صحيح رشقه صاروخيه جديده باتجاه شمال
شرق قطاع غزه
وبالتالي هذه الرشقه تكون هي الرشقه
الصاروخيه الرابعه التي تطلق من قطاع غزه
والقبه الحديديه الان بالفعل اطلقت صواريخ
جديده
قذيفه قذيفتان ثلاث اربع خمس قذائف
صاروخيه اطلقتها القبه الحديديه انفجرت في
سماء تخوم محافظه قطاع غزه الان مزيد من
الصواريخ القبه الحديديه نحو ثمانيه
صواريخ اطلقتها القبه الحديديه في محاوله
لاعتراض هذه الصواريخ او الرشقه الصاروخيه
التي اطلقت من قطاع غزه هي معركه في سماء
محافظات قطاع غزه وتخومها في الناحيه
الاخرى من الحدود بين الرشقات الصاروخيه
وبين قذائف القبه الحديديه التي تتوالى
تباعا وبالتاكيد نحن لا ندري هل بالفعل
الان كما يبدو
في منطقه اخرى هناك قذيفه
للقبه الحديديه اطلقت ايضا ولكننا لم نرى
حقيقه اطلاق اي من الصواريخ من هذه
المناطق الان ايضا الان هناك صواريخ جديده
هذا صحيح
صواريخ جديده